all right so what is your name
leviticus brown leviticus brown very
good name
yeah and where are you from from new
york harlem
yeah and how have you been out here uh
since 1991
i exited the u.s navy i'm a persian gulf
war vet
i've been united since 1991 i have one
son
and uh from a family of alcoholics of
course
and uh i don't know maybe alcoholism is
this
hereditary or i don't know it's just
learned behavior but anyway
um is alcohol your issue alcohol and
drugs
and drugs too well initially it was
alcohol
i was an alcoholic from well my dad was
an alcoholic
so i just learned some behavior traits
from him um
he derived he died from cirrhosis of the
liver of course at the age of 52.
that was the last time i've been in new
york i haven't seen my mom since
1991. so it's been a long time she's
very upset with me about it but um
this is just going on in my life where i
feel that i don't want to take
them back home to her or my siblings and
family members all of them are back in
new york
um started as an alcoholic um
after i got out the navy i like to go on
the bars
the red onion the the golden frog
yeah hey i thought i was a great dancer
you know i thought i was fantastic you
know on the dance floor
when i got drunk you know drinking a
long island iced teas
and but it came to the point where i
started crashing my car in the polls
instead of hitting the brakes i was in
the gas pedal and
uh well i mean one day i was driving
down the street
and i had a 40 ounce of beer in my lap
in schools
i was getting out you know and uh
i'm reached down to be a spill i reached
down to pick up the beer and i heard a
big thump
like you know and i looked at my
rearview mirror
i saw a lady laying in the middle of the
street
i i stomped on the gas pedal and broke
the windshield just ran
and then threw the ball away brought
some gum
thought about it for a second and i
thought maybe
it would be difficult for me to live
with myself not knowing what had
happened to this person
i went back to the scene and it was a
teacher
she had just retired that day and they
had a retirement celebration for her and
everything
but she wasn't hurt that bad she just
had some scuffs and bruises
and uh she was all right you know i felt
better about it
but um still long behold i still got a
dui
dy number one at the dui number one
i went to school did all the work that i
did in school
after school um continued to drink of
course
even going to school continued to drink
i um
got another dui dui number two this was
in long beach
after uh my wife
my son's mom decided that my drinking
was a problem
and that i should go to rehab rehab
number one
i say anything remember i've been to
about 15 rehabs by now
i know a n a c a i can quote scriptures
from any of those books
know the bible very well my name is
third book in the old testament
leviticus
so um you know of course i'm well
learned in that area
um but one day i was introduced to crack
cocaine
i had a friend and he's a levi you're
getting drunk you're throwing up all
over the place
are you really having a good time i said
man
[ __ ] we got hangovers barely getting to
work i'm gonna get to work i can't work
he said come on let's let's go over this
girl's house and uh
try something different so we go to this
girl's house nice looking
female i would think and uh
we went in the back we should leave it
come on come on in the back room and i
said what's that let's crack that sound
i'm home new york man i lived in
projects all my life man
growing up in their projects the 14th
floor you know
poor lifestyle wealthier you know i know
all about that crack stuff
i'm not i'm not i don't want to mess
with it try it just try it
so anyway i tried it and the girl
started performing
some fellatio of course i mean wow that
was fantastic
i arrived at my new drug now
from 1993
to the present day um like cocaine has
been a problem in my life
um so what happened
i was a engineer in in the navy of
course i had unlimited steam engineers
license
a universal epa certification so i
worked at power plants artco
i worked at uh i worked at um a steward
of stevenson a cogen plant
very good very good money department of
public works stationary engineer
very good money however payday would
come
when payday would come i would no call
new show at work
what's going on with levi hey you know
what i had
my heart my chest started hurting that
going to ha
what could you you couldn't have just
called me like
i could have but um i didn't i just
didn't
okay they would let it slide of course
but this began to be
uh repetitious of course
every job that i've had and i believe i
was very good at what i was doing
because they would hire me back to back
i mean
i would go to the interviews and and
they started asking me questions
i would name all these different pieces
of equipment i worked and
i would talk about different laboratory
tests would perform on boiling water and
salt water and all these different
systems so
they know i was very well learned in
their job
they would have given me a chance but
same thing would happen from 1993
to 2007 i almost had like 30 jobs
they kept hiring me um of course came
homeless
became homeless in downtown long beach
uh my family
got tired of me calling and asking for
money all the time
what's going on with you okay you're on
drugs
but we're not gonna give you any money
anymore levi
we're not we're just you need to come
home no i can't go home
ruin your life
bingo end up sleeping in missions
cardboard boxes
downtown long beach getting arrested for
possession
crack cocaine in and out of jail for
crack cocaine
uh one day uh my wife before she
actually left
she you know she said that um i can't
deal with it anymorely like
i just i just can't you know i would i
would be outside
the the townhouse apartments and call
and say hey baby
um i got a flat tire on so-and-so and so
on street
can you come uh come over here and help
me and as soon as she would go
leave i would watch her leave the house
and soon she would leave the house i'd
run in there
take the vcr dvd player or take whatever
little money that i had or
ordered and she's gonna leave right look
baby i look i got a job
i will replace it when i get paid
i came to a point where she says i can't
do it anymore
you're losing your jobs you have no
income now
i'm tired of carrying you from payday to
payday uh
you just won't go to meetings you just
you're going in and out of rehab from
the va rehab the salvation army rehab
to to this rehab and that rehab uh
just going right so
my son now is 26 years old i still pay
child support because what happened was
she took the income that i was getting
during the time down working
and took it to court and of course i was
somewhere smoking crack so i didn't
report the court
so they gave her whatever money that
they felt was necessary for uh
you know take care of the child by the
time i found out about i was
60 000 in a hole in in child
uh care services so
um i owed it to her not to the county
because she worked she had a very good
job she's a social worker by the way
for department of social services
um 2012 so as of this day i'm still
paying child support
i haven't seen my son in years and uh
that bothers me also how's your son he's
26 now
and uh haven't seen him in like 10 years
and it bothers me he graduated high
school and
you know no no communication whatsoever
uh no communication with the mother
whatsoever uh
i find myself now downtown homeless
at the age of 50. my income a pretty
good income
i get a va pension of 3 000 a month in a
social security disability income
of 1500 and you know what
by the fifth or seventh of the month
either it's all old out or it's all gone
my addiction is is pretty bad
and uh what happens is i credit doping
i don't have the money to pay for it so
they double it up on me and
i go to lone sharks and they double it
up on me and
so it's a very sad lifestyle
you know i'm really having a difficult
time dealing with them
my heart's just completely broken by so
many things that's going on in my life
another rehab i've been to them all
i mean there i don't feel there's
nothing else left for me to learn when
it comes to
narcotics anonymous or recovery period
i've been through a bunch of them but
for some odd reason or another
i go back to the substance that devours
my lifestyle
that takes everything away from me and i
find myself back
downtown craving the lifestyle
see addiction to me is more than just
smoking crack it's it's
the lifestyle the i get adrenaline rush
from
running down the street or or somebody
doing something
that you know that depressing
it's a weird sense of uh enjoyment
but um all i can remember is that one
good time that one good hit i had
that's all i remember all the other time
but usually every time i get it
and i do it i find myself not having a
good time anymore
just doing it because i'm addicted to it
and uh have you ever been queen before
two years at one time
i went to a recovery center and stayed
there for a year and a half
after a year and a half in the recovery
house i stayed clean for a year after
that so
about two and a half years but um
what have what has to happen i believe
is i have to stay in recovery house
for at least two years in a facility
uh these six month programs these 90-day
programs
they won't work for me i need time to
to really see what's going on inside me
i mean you know when
when i was in the recovery program
program uh you know a lot of things on
the surface
you know that i just don't see comes out
when i write when i journal
and get deep within myself to find out
what's really going on with me um
i you know i was raised in the household
we don't tell what's going on you know
dad beat mom up
no we don't talk about that outside the
house there's an alcoholic
and he he does all this stuff in the
house and
we don't i've been learning i've learned
to stuff my feelings and my emotions
and walk around like everything's okay
when inside i'm
just waiting first and then so alcohol
and drugs
is a sedative to help me control
right exactly right but tell me about
your childhood
childhood poor introvert uh
and ashamed uh poor you know we don't
welfare that
my brother's clothes on
hey you clean your brother's pants did
he had those on yesterday
look at those shoes you got you know
that kind of childhood um
brothers i think big ears you know
didn't talk to anybody
did finish high school a year late you
know
but i did graduate high school but i was
very
embarrassed or very um
hard on myself man because i mean i
thought that i was never good enough
i felt that that that what was going on
in my life
you know being in the projects and pc
elevators and pixie steered wells and
sometimes elevators didn't work
i'd woke up 14 flights of stairs and
then once i get up there
you know i gotta eat liver or whatever
whatever the case may be
i'm just not making excuses for my life
today all of those that's that's the way
that it was
and uh i wanted to do so much better for
myself that's why
you know my brother was going to jail
and all my family members was going to
jail for serving
heroin and cracking harlem which was big
during that time
i chose not to do it i want to do more
for myself i want to i want to be
somebody i want to achieve some things
but i felt ver i fell victim to the very
thing that they want to do
yeah it's consumed my life
[Music]
thank you so much for sharing your
thoughts thank you amazing
thank you like
do goodbye see hope for you do they
hopefully
getting clean and you're like together
or i i do
i do because i'm trying to do it less
frequent now
i'm trying to um i'm going to go back
into another program i i have no choice
because i mean i can't figure it out on
my own
you know if i try to go into my own head
and figure out what's going on with me
i can't do it i need help and without
help
i do not stand a chance i need somebody
to help me
so i'm gonna have to go back to the va
and let's try to do it again but this
time don't leave in 90 days don't leave
in six months
stay the whole year and get a foundation
to where i can i can build on
the right that's right and it'll open
the door the rest of my life i mean
everything would be much better i
wouldn't be homeless on the streets
and you know smoking crack and running
around with these [ __ ] by getting hiv
and aids you know what i mean yeah you
had your son back in your life and i had
my son back in my life and i can go see
my mom
was crying you know he broke my heart
with my mom she answers the phone
hey how you doing hey mom's leaving me
back
find me come home what's
going on
oh god i couldn't i could
at least i had to go do some drugs right
now
i broke a heart she's deserving
so
this is something i gotta live with
she's 70 years old now she doesn't have
i ain't got that much time left levi hey
you need to come home
i just pray let me tell pray
that um things get better but but
the only way things are going to get
better as long as i have to try to do
better i have to do something proactive
to make it better
i just can't wish to get better i have
to do something about it
that's it
thank you so much
you